[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt nächste woche ist er bereits ostern
und ich habe mir gedacht machen wir mal
wieder was schönes besonderes mit
merkels ich verwende jetzt die mails zum
fertigen anmischen ihr könnt aber auch
gerne mein video anschauen das basic
rezept zum irak lässt bei möglichst
muster im prinzip nur wissen alles was
ihr machen möchtet müsst ihr am tag
vorher zu bereiten und einfrieren so
kommt ihr nämlich zum besseren und
richtig guten ergebnis ich hab das eben
auch gemacht und werde euch jetzt mal
zeigen wie ich die freianlage hersteller
für die fruchtbarkeit nämlich 120 km
roten saft 300 gramm erdbeeren im gipsy
tiefgefrorene und zehn gramm magath habe
ich jetzt bereits auftauen lassen
und ich gebe es jetzt hier in einen topf
zur see sorgt könnt ihr natürlich auch
ganz viel fährt beim nehmen oder
natürlich auch anderes obst rindes gerne
habt sie kommt der saft dazu wer möchte
kann hier auch ein bisschen likör
zufügen jetzt ein bisschen zerstampfen
und direkt aus aka aka zufügen als
pflanzliches geliermittel gelatine könnt
ihr auch benutzen aber da ist die
zubereitung weise ein bisschen anders
das ihnen darf nämlich nicht kochen ich
werde hier die frucht maße aufkochen
lassen etwas zerdrücken während dem
kochen so werden wir wären schön klein
ihr könnt natürlich auch pürieren und
dann dass ich auf kochen und mindestens
zwei minuten lang sprudelnd kochen
durch das kochen witters agatha und
bildet beim abkühlen dann schön fest und
jetzt fühle ich die masse mit einem
teelöffel hier in die silikon vom 31
prinzip nur wichtig dass die furt anlage
kleiner ist als die torte später so dass
später die creme die frucht einlage
umhüllt
jetzt habe ich die förmchen gefüllt und
habe noch etwas übrig die förmchen als
die masse darin die steht ziemlich
schnell und wird auch sehr schnell fest
das heißt ich gebe es jetzt einfach in
den gefrierschrank lass es frieren kann
dann die förmchen herauslösen und die
übrige maße auch nochmal einführen die
briger masse wird natürlich bis dahin
noch abkühlen aber ich kann sie einfach
auf mein herz noch einmal erwärmen das
sie flüssig wird und dann nochmal eine
zweite portion die frucht einlage ist es
schön gefroren ich nehme sie jetzt
heraus es geht auch wirklich super
einfach toll aus guckt mal richtig
wirklich das jetzt hier einfach rein zur
vorbereitung bis ich dann die creme
gleich fertig habe und frisst es so
lange auch noch mal ein und das geräusch
das ist übrigens der liegt nämlich
gerade draußen gerade um alex die
terrasse und entgingen
[Musik]
die frucht einlagen sind jetzt fertig
jetzt kann ich die schokoladen mousse
herstellen für die schokoladen mousse
verwende ich 250 gramm sahne 100 gramm
weiße schokolade 5 gramm gemahlene
gelatine das ist relativ
drei esslöffel sahne 1 1 und 1 eigelb
zuerst gebe ich jetzt die sahne in einen
topf und lasst ihr kurz aufkochen
die sahne ist jetzt aufgekocht ich habe
jetzt den herd ausgestellt jetzt kommt
hier die schokolade rein und wird
solange gerührt bis sie einfach
geschmolzen ist dann fühle ich die
schoko sahne um und stellt sie sofort in
den kühlschrank damit so schön kalt wird
die schoko sahne ist jetzt schön kalt
die kann ich noch mal kurz in einem
kühlschrank stellen und die relative und
lasse in der sahne einweichen
einfach kurz einrühren und so etwa fünf
minuten stehen lassen und den derzeit
kann ich schon mal die eier verrühren
ich habe zehn wasserbad also lasst unten
im topf wasser aufkochen und werde jetzt
hier das ei und das eigelb darin
verrührt einfach um natürlich auch die
keime abzutöten das ei wird dadurch
stabiler und ich verwende jetzt
eindämmung ist damit einfach schön
locker wird ihr könnt den part im
konzept auch weglassen und einfach die
schoko sahne aufschlagen und mit der
gelatine entweder binden oder sogar die
gelatine weglassen
ich mache es einfach damit spätere
messen ein bisschen lockerer wird so
dass hier einfach für etwa fünf minuten
erhitzen und dabei schön rühren
die eier meister vom herd herunter die
röhre ich hier gleich kalt und kann
jetzt aber über dem warmen wasserbad
die gelatine erwärmen und da ist einfach
nur wichtig dass gelatine niemals kochen
darf sonst verliert sie ihre binder
eigenschaft
es geht doch relativ schnell weil es
wenig masse ist und jetzt kann ich hier
die schoko sahne auch schön steif
schlagen
dafür muss der schneebesen schön kalt
sein jetzt wo ich schnell nach der
gelatine
das ist wirklich ein rezept ohne wandel
extrakt extrakt in den erdbeer vanille
passt gut zu erdbeeren also könnt ihr
gerne mit reinnehmen oder auch in die
schoko sahne
aber ich lasse den geschmack von weiße
schokolade erdbeere und später dann
überzog und zwar eigentlich ein kreuz
machen den kalender
doch so weit jetzt die gelatine in die
eier masse einrühren
dadurch dass die eier massa keine mega
kalte masse ist kann ich auch einfach
die gelatine hier dazu geben ohne die
temperatur anzugleichen jetzt noch schön
die schoko sahne unterheben
schon ist die schoko muss fertig und zum
einfüllen ihnen die seele ton form
nämlich jetzt hier einen spritzbeutel
mit nach thüle vorne
das ganze im spritzbeutel ständer sich
beide hände frei
und jetzt nämlich die große silikonform
und wichtig ist beim einfüllen nur
zuerst die creme und mit der creme auch
abschließen und alles andere kommt in
die mitte also das nehme ich hier mit
der lochmühle ein bisschen creme ein
[Musik]
dann die frucht einlage und zwar kopf
über das praktisch die gerade seite oben
ist dann erneut etwas krämer ein
bisschen klopfen damit sich die creme
verteilt ich bin ihr möchtet einfachen
löffelbiskuits so spart man sich auch
das backen leicht rein drücken und mit
der creme abschließen
[Musik]
jetzt hier einfach schön glatt abziehen
und einfrieren ein fan ist ganz wichtig
wegen der oakley ist damit die später
richtig schön knapp drüber läuft und
hier ist auch wichtig dass wirklich die
luft raus geklopft wird also ein paar
mal auf die arbeitsfläche klopfen damit
die luftbläschen verschwinden und die
creme schön glatt wird ein film etwa
vier bis fünf stunden oder einfach über
nacht zu mach ich hier jetzt in die
taschen gefroren und können fertig
dekoriert werden
ich habe mich jetzt hier für die schoko
variante entschieden für die dunkle und
im prinzip braucht ihr da nur noch die
milch dazu also 400 milliliter mint egal
ob 15 oder 3,5 prozent und ein päckchen
wörtlich dem milch werde jetzt hier in
einem topf ausgekocht
und sobald die milch kocht dann einfach
den herd ausschalten und das höhere
games pulver einrühren
am besten klümpchen frei ich kann nicht
mit der einen hand schütteln während die
andere dreht
[Musik]
und jetzt ist die maße natürlich noch zu
heiß jetzt dass ich sehr abkühlen ist
etwa 20 bis 25 minuten ich früher immer
mal wieder und dann sollte es so etwa 35
grad haben also ungefähr hand war
denn dann können wir die törtchen damit
übergießen
merkel ist fast schon die perfekte
temperatur 36,7 habe ich momentan aber
ich streiche sie es sowieso noch durch
ein hase damit die letzten luftbläschen
verschwinden und dann kühlt sie ja auch
noch ein bisschen herunter das heißt
dann wird sie richtig gut
und während sich hier noch durch läuft
kann ich schon mal die törtchen lösen
[Musik]
oh ich hab ich's kleine blogger
luftbläschen drin nicht schlimm aber
auch nicht ganz schön denn da habe ich
dann eine kleine macke drin aber da tun
oder so ich mache erst mal die 3 die
restlichen friere ich so lange wieder
ein damit sie nicht warm werden und
jetzt am besten auf dem abkühlen gitter
setzen und darunter ein blech zum
auffangen denn die übrigen ist die
kammer wieder wahr machen und dann eben
erneut verwenden
und jetzt in einem sprung von vorne nach
hinten fließen lassen
für das schön alles bedeckt ist
[Musik]
ein bisschen klopfen jetzt schön
abfließt und klassik ist einfach für
etwa drei bis vier minuten stehen wie
gesagt die übrige die fange ich nochmal
auf erwarten sie in der mikrowelle lasst
ihr nochmal auf 35 grad herunterkühlt
kann auch die übrigen drei dann
dekorieren ich habe jetzt noch so kleine
ostereier schokoeier die gibt es in
jedem supermarkt auch von verschiedenen
marken und die könnte jetzt ganz einfach
aufwerten und aufhübschen mit metallic
spray das natürlich es war ich mir jetzt
gold und kupfer dann einfach einen
sprung
[Musik]
ich möchte es so ein bisschen
dann könnte dann auch gerne noch so und
der hand roll- und der rest farbe
verteilung oder einfach umdrehen und von
der zweiten seite auch gestreut gespräch
[Musik]
zum anrichten auf dem teller habe ich
jetzt hier noch sahne sonderfahrt und
vanille extrakt dann schlag ich jetzt
einfach die sahne steif
[Musik]
die same habe ich jetzt oben gefüllt in
einen spritzbeutel und hier vorne habe
ich so eine flache drauf die törtchen
sind fertig die sahne ist bereit die
eier sind auch schon getrocknet und
jetzt wird dekoriert ich nehme hier
einfach noch ein bisschen erst baris
usta gras zwar ist das papier
ich finde das macht schon was her
dann ein schönes törtchen
[Musik]
jetzt nehmen wir die spritztour mit der
dicken seite nach unten und macht hier
oben so eine geschenkte linie obendrauf
dann in westasien
[Musik]
als gefriergetrocknete erdbeeren
und hier unten noch die eier rein und
dann ist er fertig und so könnt ihr die
törtchen wirklich super gut vorbereiten
denn die müssen jetzt noch vor dem
verzehr auf kühlschranktemperatur kommen
also das eis deutschen müssen noch mal
schön aufbauen damit man es angeht an
löffeln oder angaben kann und ich lasse
jetzt gleich glaube ich mal den murat
probieren
[Musik]
das ist ein mädchen das sich mit super
aus schlägl knicks mit banane
schlagstock bei maler fritz ist das hab
ich nur fürs foto angelastet probiert
aber abreißen gestellt wird alles auf
einmal gelungen drin mit himbeeren und
eine weiße schokoladen wohnt weil es
etwas für ostern oder doch ein schönes
schweren klasse schmeckte so süß ist gut
weil die hinweise habe ich nämlich nicht
gesetzt das heißt es nützlich sein und
die creme müsst ihr auch gut so
sehr schön also falls sie an ostern auch
eure männer oder eure gäste glücklich
machen wollt dann packt doch dieses mal
bläst örtchen bat mich sogar falsch es
war noch weg den ich habe den biskuit
benutzt diesen löffel bis wird dh ihr
braucht nur einen kühlschrank oder der
gefriertruhe
das wäre am besten und dann könnt ihr
das nicht nachmachen finden kann jetzt
aber er ließ mir des erscheinens ich hab
dich aus schaute baustelle york die
traurigen kurvenreichen dann mach du
hast du wirklich willst
das ist doch ostern scharf wird kein
ostern du bist so ein osterhase viel
spaß beim nachmachen
bis zum nächsten mal musste aus bloßer
gras fressen das ist es her da hausten
und die eier gegessen habe ich einfach
schokoeier genommen und einfach gold
besprüht group könnte alles darauf essen
kohlhepp und gar nicht so schwierig
[Musik]